seguimos en la página 283 y vamos con el
problema 68 el problema 68 nos pide
determinar el promedio o bien la media
aritmética de j y k es decir queremos
determinar jota más k dividido entre dos
queremos determinar esto de aquí
básicamente lo que queremos determinar
es la suma de j y k
vamos a ver qué opciones nos dan los
incisos en el inciso 1 nos dicen que el
promedio de j más 2 y k más 4 es 11 o
sea j más 2 más camas 4
entre 2 es igual a 11 y de aquí queremos
ver si podemos determinar este valor yo
digo que si mira juntamos jota con acá y
nos queda jota más acá entre 2
+ 24 entre 2 o sea 3 es igual a 11 y
restando 3 de ambos lados jota más k
entre 2 es igual a 8 entonces este por
sí mismo responde la pregunta y en el
inciso 2 nos dicen que el promedio de j
acá y 14 o sea jota más k más 14 entre 3
entre 3 es igual a 10 a 10 muy bien aquí
no podemos hacer el mismo truco pero lo
que sí podemos hacer es despejar jota
más que multiplicando por tres de ambos
lados nos queda que jota más cara más 14
es igual a 30
de modo que jota más k es igual a 16 y
dividiendo entre 2 de ambos lados
regresamos a que jota más k entre 2 o
está más cara entre 2 es igual a 8 muy
bien entonces cada una de estas por sí
misma nos permite responder la pregunta
y entonces la respuesta es
vamos ahora el problema 69 en el
problema 69 nos dice que paula y sandra
paula y sandra son dos de las personas
que venden boletos para que el club x
recupere algo de dinero ok entonces
seguro hizo algún gasto pero bueno están
vendiendo boletos de rifa y nos dice que
entre las dos vendieron 100 boletos los
que vendió paula más los que vendió
sandra es igual haciendo y lo que nos
pide determinar es cuántos tickets o
cuántos boletos vendió paula
cuántos boletos vendió paula en el
inciso 1 la información que nos dan es
que sandra vendió dos terceras partes de
lo que vendió paula sandra vendió dos
terceras partes de lo que vendió paula
aquí ya deberías de reconocer
inmediatamente que tenemos dos
ecuaciones lineales con dos variables y
por lo tanto podemos determinar el valor
de p ahorita lo vamos a hacer déjame
pasar primero al inciso 2 pero ya en el
examen en el simat de suficiencia de
información debes de darte cuenta de
esto inmediatamente y responder que con
esto es suficiente pero vamos a ver qué
dice el inciso 2 en el inciso 2 dice que
sandra
vendió el 8 por ciento 0.08 del total de
boletos vendidos del total pero ojo
paula y sandra sólo eran dos de las
personas que estaban vendiendo entonces
este total pues puede ser más de 100 de
hecho debe ser siendo más verdad y aquí
no tenemos nada de información para pues
determinar cuál es este valor de té y
por lo tanto no podemos saber nada
acerca de p vale de hecho ni siquiera
habla acerca de p entonces este de aquí
no es suficiente ni siquiera
combinándolo con este de acá porque
tenemos esta tierra y el 1 si es
suficiente y para mostrarte que es
suficiente vamos a resolver la ecuación
sale entonces nos dicen que ese es dos
tercios de p entonces p más dos tercios
de p sustituyó la s es igual a 100
multiplicando por tres de ambos lados
tenemos que 3 p2p es igual a 300 y aquí
tenemos 5 p es igual a 300 y por lo
tanto p es igual a 60
entonces pudimos responderlo pero esto
hubiera sido una pérdida de tiempo ya en
el examen del yí matt vale bueno la
respuesta sería a la opción 1 es
suficiente y la 2 es inútil vamos ahora
el problema 70
problemas 70 tenemos muchos tonos de
azul es bueno en el problema 70 nos
piden determinar si x es igual a 3 - b x
bueno vamos a ver que nos dan de
información en el inciso 1 la
información que tenemos es que x
programas b
x x b es igual a 3 esto de aquí es
suficiente verdad y te lo voy a mostrar
simplemente tenemos que utilizar la
propiedad distributiva aquí para para
llegar a que x a más
xb es igual a 3 restamos x de ambos
lados
ekiza es igual a 3 - x b y estos
productos pues les podemos cambiar el
orden y eso no alt
no altera el resultado de modo que de
aquí obtenemos que x es igual a 3 - b x
entonces eso es justo lo que queríamos
ver sale ahora vamos al 2 en el 2 de la
información que nos dan es que a es
igual a b que es igual a 1 a 1.5 y nos
dicen que x es igual a 1 esta es toda la
información que necesitamos verdad
entonces por supuesto que ésta por sí
misma nos va a ayudar a responder esta
pregunta de hecho podemos podemos checar
lo a por x sería 1.5 y eso nos estamos
preguntando si es igual
a 3 b x x 3 menos 1.5 y si verdad esto
de aquí sí es cierto pero lo importante
es que esta información nos permite
determinar si esta igualdad es verdadera
o no estaría aquí por sí misma también
entonces la respuesta de aquí sería de
de muy bien ahora vamos al problema 71
71 en el problema 71 nos dicen que
cierta cantidad de personas escribieron
en un papel uno de los primeros 30
enteros positivos aunque entonces 12
30 algunas personas escribieron algunos
de estos números en un papel y lo que
nos preguntan es determinar si hubo
repeticiones
que si hubo repeticiones bueno vamos a
ver que que tenemos de información el
inciso 1 lo que nos dice es que la
cantidad de personas que escribieron
numerito fue mayor o igual que 40
entonces la cantidad de personas mayor o
igual que 40 pues pensemos a ver si
tenemos 40 personas o más que escriben
un número en un papelito y esos números
solo van del 1 al 30 entonces
definitivamente tiene que haber repetido
es verdad es decir estas personas que
son 40 las tenemos que repartir en estos
números que sólo son 30 y por lo tanto
debe haber repeticiones entonces en este
caso si podemos determinar si hay
repeticiones o no y la respuesta es que
sí si hay repeticiones vamos a ver qué
nos dice el inciso 2 en el inciso 2 lo
que nos dice es que la cantidad de
personas que escribieron en un papelito
fue menor que 70
menor que 70 pues estoy aquí en realidad
no nos dice nada verdad o sea puede que
simplemente hayamos tenido una persona
que escribió en un papelito y escribió
el 3 o lo que sea y pues definitivamente
no hubo repeticiones o si las personas
son menos que 70 pues pudieron haber
sido 40 y entonces sí hubo repeticiones
vaya esta información por sí misma no
nos permite determinar si hubo
repeticiones o no y por lo tanto la
respuesta sería ah
ok vamos al problema 72 el problema 72
nos dice lo siguiente aquí tenemos un
dibujo déjame hacerlo es una es como un
segmento donde hay cuatro puntos
marcados que se llaman abs y de entonces
por aquí tenemos aa
por aquí ave por aquí hace y por acá de
ok entonces nos dice en la figura de
arriba tenemos que cede le gana a abc la
pregunta es si cede le gana a bs bueno
pues vamos a ver qué información nos dan
el inciso uno nos dice que ate es igual
a 20 ate es igual a 20 eso simplemente
es que esta longitud mide 20 verdad 20
pero pues esto no nos dice nada acerca
de cede por ejemplo ni bbc entonces ésta
por sí misma no es suficiente a lo mejor
podemos combinarla con el 2 en el 2 nos
dice que
avn es igual a cd
haced o sea nos está diciendo que este
mide lo mismo que este segmento de acá y
queremos ver si se delegan a bs pero
todavía no tenemos suficiente
información porque a lo mejor hay mucho
repartido en estos cachitos y poquito
aquí o poquito en estos cachitos y mucho
acá no sé por ejemplo podría ser que
esté mida 5 este 10 y este 5 entonces en
este caso b se le gana a cede o bien
podría ser que esto fuera 8 esto 4 y
esto 8 ahí otra vez de longitud total 20
pero ahora tenemos que éste es menor que
este de acá entonces esta información
por sí misma no nos dice nada está por
sí misma no nos dice nada y ni siquiera
combinando las dos podemos determinar si
se delegan a abc o no porque aquí
tenemos tenemos dos casos que satisfacen
esto de acá que satisfacen ambas
condiciones pero en las cuales en los
cuales uno cumple esto y el otro no
entonces la respuesta sería
ni siquiera combinando los dos incisos
podemos determinar la respuesta